[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal nous sommes le
mercredi 19 janvier voici les titres de
cette édition
pour pallier l'absentéisme du personnel
scolaire en raison de la crise sanitaire
l académie de versailles a lancé une
opération massive de recrutement une
démarche engagée début janvier pour
remplacer les professeurs ne pouvons pas
à se rendre en cour à rambouillet un
nouvel hôpital devrait sortir de terre
d'ici huit ans en attendant le site
actuel s'offre de nouveaux services à
parmi lesquels le suivi des personnes
atteintes d'obésité le service
rythmologie ou encore la maternité est
le point sur sa mutation dans ce journal
trouver des solutions pour lutter contre
l'abstention c'était l'objectif de la
table ronde organisée à x campus hier
soir la réunion s'est déroulée en
présence de citoyens de spécialistes et
d'élus locaux dont la députée nathalie a
poussé f et nous parlerons a également
des circonscriptions du département à
suivre pour les législatives et puis une
navette segnora été mises en circulation
à maurepas
[Musique]
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire de
nombreux enseignants surveillants mais
également personnel administratif sont
absents face à cette situation
l'académie de versailles a lancé une
opération massive de recrutement elle
compte embaucher à 500 personnes parmi
le personnel retraité de l'éducation
nationale ou encore les jeunes diplômés
mathilde de franck ou et margot gésiers
en raison de l'épidémie de kobe 19
l'académie de versailles estime que le
taux d'absentéisme des enseignants et
personnels administratifs est monté à 10
% voire à 15% et souvent les professeurs
ne pouvant plus se rendre en classe sont
rarement remplacé par contre ce qui est
plus difficile c'est au niveau des
et des professeurs quand ils sont pas là
bas ils ont du mal à être remplacé donc
on doit garder nos enfants un peu à la
dernière minute donc ça c'est assez
difficile à gérer et après c'est pareil
au niveau de la cantine des fois y'a pas
assez de personnel donc on nous demande
de les garder donc on faut qu'on
s'arrange donc ça c'est un peu compliqué
on est confronté tout ça la réalité du
manque de personnel
le ministre peut toujours parler de
remplaçons mêlée prend place on les voit
pas on les voyait pas déjà avant et avec
le co vite c'est encore plus fait encore
pire depuis le début de l'année scolaire
l'académie de versailles a déjà recruté
trois mille trois cents personnes mais
pour pallier le manque d'effectif dû à
la crise sanitaire à la lancée depuis
début janvier une vaste opération de
recrutement depuis la reprise de janvier
nous avons passé un cran supplémentaire
pour aller chercher d'autres personnes
notamment des étudiants qui seraient
qualifiés il faut une licence pour
enseigner mais également des personnes
retraitées et d'autres contractuels qui
ont les qualifications
depuis deux semaines nous avons recruté
un petit peu plus de 200 nouvelles
personnes et au total on nous en faut
encore il nous en faudrait encore 300
pour compléter nos chances outre les
enseignants le personnel administratif
et les surveillants sont également en
tension il ya un autre besoin qui est
grand pour nous c'est ce qu'on appelle
les assistants d'éducation ce sont des
surveillants dans les collèges et dans
les lycées
l'année dernière nous avions mis en
place des équipes mobiles de
surveillants qu'ils pouvaient se
déplacer au four au gré des besoins des
collèges et des lycées dans
l'établissement amont à un autre nous
avons plus d'une centaine de postes à
pourvoir en ce sens certains territoires
des yvelines sont plus touchés la
rectrice de l'académie de versailles
évoque notamment les villes de
chanteloup-les-vignes aubergenville ou
encore ben
notre journaliste a également abordé
avec la rectrice de l'académie de
versailles cette affaire de
l'enseignante menace est accusé de
racisme pour avoir utilisé une photo du
rappeur soprano lors d'un cours sur
l'évolution pour rappel la professeure
de svt a remplacé le croquis de l'homo
sapiens par un portrait de l'artiste
dans une prise et chronologique elle
aurait souhaité rendre son cours plus
attractif une de ses élèves de troisième
il une comparaison racistes entre le
singe et le rappeur le père de
l'étudiante a posté la photo sur
facebook menacés sur les réseaux sociaux
l'institutrice se rejettent toute
assimilation elle raciste elle a porté
plainte les services de police lui ont
conseillé de s'exfiltrer en dehors de
l'ile-de-france l'académie ensuite avait
signalé les choses aux forces de
sécurité
et puis là enseignante déposé plainte
elle a pu déposer table parce que nous
lui avons accordé ce qu'on appelle la
protection fonctionnelle
suite à cette affaire est l'enseignante
a demandé à changer d'établissement mais
aussi de territoire
l'enseignante a en effet été
immédiatement placé en congé
pour la réalité temporaire plutôt à nos
services c'est un peu technique mais en
tout cas c'était une manière de
l'éloigner et nous sommes aujourd'hui en
train de travailler à la stabilisation
de son prochain post est le père à
l'origine à des menaces a été jugé le 15
novembre dernier il a reçu une peine de
six mois de prison ferme
[Musique]
l'hôpital de rambouillet est en pleine
mutation c'est acté un nouvel hôpital va
sortir de terre donc à rambouillet un
projet qui devrait voir le jour à 10 et
8 ans à l'horizon 2030 est un donc et
pour aborder le sujet avec nous et
elisabeth calmont bonsoir un saint vous
vous êtes donc la directrice du centre
hospitalier de rambouillet ce nouvel
hôpital c'est un projet d'envergure est
ce qu'on peut présenter justement un
petit peu ce projet pourquoi c'est
devenu nécessité aussi aujourd'hui alors
c'est vrai que c'est un c'est une
opportunité extraordinaire
qui peut aboutir grâce à une réelle
solidarité que nous avons entre nous
entre madame la présidente du conseil de
surveillance wernick matillon sofie
d'hoore je ré qui est médecin qui
représente la collectivité médical de
l'hôpital et nous sommes très très unie
pour pouvoir rénover notre hôpital
complètement leur construire sur un site
neuf sur la base de projets médical dax
stratégique de développement au bénéfice
de la population de notre territoire
donc c'est un enjeu fondamental pour
nous sommes très heureux de cette
nouvelle est ce qu'on a déjà une idée ou
pas du tout du site où ça pourrait
s'implanter pour le moment non nous
avons plusieurs plusieurs idées mais qui
reste encore à finaliser donc on l'a dit
ça devrait voir le jour à l'horizon 2030
et un en quoi ça va se différencier du
centre actuel est-ce qu'on est un peu
une idée aussi des grandes étapes de ce
projet alors tout est à construire mais
bien entendu nous allons aussi prendre
le sens de notre vécu notamment avec lé
là la crise que nous sommes en train de
traverser je pense qu'effectivement
cette crise aura un impact sur les
nouveaux établissements à à construire
nous conférons probablement différemment
après la crise et avant la crise et en
tout état de cause ce sera un
établissement qui sera au service des
axes médicaux médicaux soignants et ça
c'est très important c'est à dire que l'
architecture
s'adaptera aux soins que nous voulons
donner aux patients donc aujourd'hui
nous avons un établissement qui compte
18 pavillons avec qui ont été construits
pour certains dans les années 30 50 en
2007 pour le dernier donc forcément le
l'hôpital de demain sera probablement
beaucoup plus rassemblé que l'hôpital
actuel et l'hôpital de demain comme vous
comme vous les appelez justement
l'objectif c'est de remplacer le site
actuel si j'ai bien compris absolument
et et donc quel est l'avenir du site
actuel est ce qu on a déjà une idée ou
pas attendu pour nous aider à financer
la reconstruction de notre hôpital très
bien et donc le projet est soutenu par
l' agence régionale de santé dans le
cadre notamment du ségur de la syntaxe
est ce que on peut faire peut-être un
point sur le budget vous êtes un peu
aidé par eux mais qu'elle est en terme
de budget
mais nous sommes très soutenus
effectivement par les pouvoirs publics
par par la rs puisque c'est un projet
qui représente à peu près une estimation
de 200 millions à l'heure toutes
dépenses confondues aa huit ans
avec à peu près 150 millions pour la
stricte partie médecine chirurgie
obstétrique
donc c'est vraiment un projet
d'envergure donc ça c'est pour justement
le projet qui va arriver dès ses 8 ans
en attendant le centre hospitalier de
rambouillet
quand même évolué avec de nouveaux
services qui se refont une beauté
notamment la maternité l'unité de
services ambulatoires la prise en charge
aussi de personnes qui souffrent
d'obésité
le service rythmologie cardiaque et donc
on a un journaliste qui est parti sur
place sur le centre actuel c'est une
fierté ce changement pour les chefs de
service il a pu le découvrir
voilà je propose de découvrir ensemble
ce sujet de bixente manière sans
équivalent dans l'unité de médecine
ambulatoire les salles ont été refaites
à neuf nouveaux espaces et nouveau
fauteuil pour assurer notamment le suivi
des personnes souffrant d'obésité
depuis un an à l'hôpital de rambouillet
on décide d'opérer ou non un patient
atteint de cette maladie
après un parcours de 6 mois minimum on
sait tous beaucoup sur l'opération et
c'est vrai que c'est un élément
important
mais la partie qui vient avant et celles
qui la partie qui dit avant et celle qui
vient après ce que nous on va essayer de
structure par ce parcours est également
importante les meilleurs résultats en
termes de perte de poids des pertes
départ à long terme en lacans donne à ce
type 2
des parcours trois rendez-vous en
hôpital de jour préopératoire sont
prévus pour faire examiner par plusieurs
spécialistes le patient avant validation
en gros groupes vraiment toutes les
spécialités dans le service au moment
des sages des gis c'est à dire que j'ai
des interventions ne pratiquement tous
les corps de métiers au niveau du
service de médecine ambulatoire
autre nouveauté dans l'hôpital le
développement de l'activité rythme aux
logiques sous spécialité de la
cardiologie c'est l'étude des anomalies
de la fréquence cardiaque et une fierté
pour tout le monde finalement c'est pour
les patientes qui sont contents alors
juste pour l'anecdote en général les
patients quand on leur dit on va vous
changer un pacemaker qui donc on les
voit en consultation et dès qu'on leur
dit qu'on peut faire cette activité
arrow boys ils sont très contents et ils
sont preneurs de le faire ici parce que
c'est juste à côté de chez eux
finalement en 1 mois 3 stimulateur
cardiaque appelé aussi pacemaker ont
déjà été posées et deux ont été changés
une nouvelle corde à l'arc du service
cardiologie et pneumologie en
perpétuelle agrandissement dans
l'hôpital je fais à l'hôpital de
rambouillet depuis 93
à l'époque il n'y avait pas de faire vis
de cardiologie ou un peu en fait
l'activité de services
s'est majoré c'est une fierté et bien
sûr
aboutissement prochaine étape en 2022
avec le développement d'un service de
rhumatologie aujourd'hui absents dans le
sud du département des spécialités qui
se poursuivront dans le projet du nouvel
hôpital prévue d'ici huit ans
et du coup on vient voir ce reportage
sur les nouveaux services en quoi c'est
important finalement d'étendre cette
offre de soins alors c'est fondamental
parce que on on touche au à la vocation
au coeur même de l'hôpital de leh de la
légitimité d'un hôpital c'est à dire
c'est de répondre aux besoins en santé
de la population ça c'est vraiment
absolument indispensable donc la
population qui est autour d'eux que
dessert notre hôpital représente à peu
près de 250000 habitants il va y avoir
autant des jeunes couples avec des
projets d'enfants d'où le dynamisme
maternité mais également une part de
plus en plus importante de population de
plus de 60 65 ans donc avec également
une prédominance des pathologies
chroniques donc nous devons à tout prix
en permanence nous adapter à cette
demande offrir vraiment les soins dans
la population a besoin et c'est y
compris important pour notre hôpital à
venir parce que un hôpital est vivant il
faut en permanence qu'il soit en
mouvement on ne reconstruit pas à
l'hôpital vide donc il est vraiment à
tout à fait essentiel pour nous que nous
continuons dans cette dynamique de
développement des activités au service
de la population et on lit aussi en lien
avec nos partenaires puisque ont tout à
l'heure vous avez mis en exergue
l'activité de rythmologie c'est vrai que
l elle démarre très très fort et c'est
une activité que nous menons en lien
très étroit avec l'hôpital de versailles
le service de cardiologie de l'hôpital
de versailles qui fait partie de notre
groupement hospitalier de territoire et
lille sud et bien sûr aussi avec la
pitié salpêtrière qui est un des indes
épaule en la matière un pôle européen en
termes de rythmologie cardiaque donc on
vraiment nous avons beaucoup de chance
de pouvoir avoir une activité telle que
celle ci est au plus près pour les rangs
des militants de nouveaux services
maintenant l'hôpital de rambouillet
peut-être un dernier mot avant de vous
quitter le personnel hospitalier donc
c'est un peu un autre sujet mais c'est
toujours en lien dit se sentir oubliés
par le gouvernement c'est le cas par
exemple des aides soignantes alors quel
est l'état un peu d'esprit dans votre
dans le centre hospitalier de
rambouillet alors il ya eu un certain
nombre de revalorisation des
rémunérations des professionnels de
santé à l'hôpital médicaux et non
médicaux dans le cadre des du ségur de
la santé et la dernièrement nous avons
eu à un décret qui prévoit une
revalorisation pour les infirmiers de
réanimation cette revalorisation
n'est pas accordée aux aides soignants
de ce même service de réanimation et
c'est la raison pour laquelle
actuellement nous avons un mouvement
social
parce que il y à une insatisfaction de
ces professionnels par rapport à cette
mesure elle considère avoir été
oublié par cette revalorisation très
bien l'écouter c'est noté merci beaucoup
pour cette réponse merci elizabeth quel
monde avoir été avec nous lg ne rappelle
un vous êtes et la directrice du centre
hospitalier de rambouillet merci merci
merci
[Musique]
comment lutter contre l'abstention aux
élections c'est la question qui a été
posée mardi 18 janvier lors d'une table
ronde au x campus de saint germain les
différents élus se sont réunis pour
échanger à sur ce sujet ils ont essayé
de trouver des solutions pour inciter
les citoyens à aller voter le reportage
de mélanie poké et margot gésiers
65 7 % d'abstention au second tour des
dernières régionales
un chiffre préoccupant une table ronde a
donc été organisée mardi 18 janvier au x
campus à saint-germain-en-laye cas un
vrai sujet abstention et qu'il faut
absolument affronter puisque ça indique
à malaise dans notre démocratie élus
locaux citoyens et spécialistes ont
cherché des solutions pour inciter au
vote véritablement se pose la question
du sens quel sens cela at-il à des voté
pour quoi allons nous voter par exemple
c'est pas évident pour les régionales et
départementales
parce qu'on comprend pas quel est le
rôle de ces institutions comprendre le
partage des compétences et pour ça il
faut avoir une meilleure éducation et je
crois que c'était un point très
important que ce soit une meilleure
éducation à la citoyenneté et ça se fait
dès l'école dès l'école primaire il
faudrait donc éduquer mais aussi
simplifier c'est surtout la
compréhension fine plus fine des
institutions du rôle de chacun une
simplification qui me semble ressortir
des attentes des citoyens ce soir dans
l'assistance les personnes présentes
prenait part au débat l'initiative a été
bien accueillie je pense que c'est à
renouveler je continue à travailler sur
ce sur cet élan si on veut changer la
situation je sais que les jeunes sont
évidemment très occupée par l'abstention
après moi je sais je suis un jeune assez
politisé donc je venais pas vraiment
pour moi mais bon c'était aussi pour
savoir pour en apprendre plus c'est
l'élection présidentielle résistent
encore à l'abstention en 2017 elle
s'élève à 25% au second tour la
prochaine aura lieu en avril
et on reste en politique la 11e
circonscription rassemble les cantons de
saint cyr l'école elle trappe et une
fraction de ceux de chevreuse et puis de
maurepas elle sera l'un des enjeux des
prochaines élections législatives dont
les yvelines d'abord prise par la gauche
puis par la république en marche pour
basculer finalement républicains tout ça
en l'espace de quatre ans et les
précisions de bixente malien santisteva
de regarder
la 11e circonscription un espace mi
rural me urbain rassemblant 110000
yvelinois qui avait élu en 2010 est
nadia et de la république en marche
nommé ministre délégué auprès de la
cohésion des territoires la députée
avait dû quitter son poste en 2020
pierre lui ce candidat pour assurer le
maintien de la circonscription au parti
du président emmanuel macron est
éliminée dès le premier tour et on
retrouve un duel gauche droite entre le
républicain philippe benassaya et
sandrine grand gang de génération s pour
le second tour de la législative
partielle de septembre 2020 nous allons
aborder deux thématiques au cours de la
prochaine demi heure philippe benassaya
vous avez choisi de parler de sécurité
s'entraîneront gang vous souhaitez
évoqué l'environnement qu'on est face à
une crise sans précédent sur le plan
sanitaire sur le plan environnemental
sur climatique et donc sur le plan
social parce que bien sûr tout est lié
et et il faut qu'on soit en capacité
finalement de proposer dès maintenant
des mesure qui qu'ils soient à la
hauteur des défis que nous rencontrons
aujourd'hui quand on parle de sécurité
c'est la première de nos libertés n'a
pas de sécurité sans liberté il ya la
liberté sont sécurité je leur parle
assez qu'aujourd'hui ce pays n'est plus
tenu sentiment d'insécurité comme vous
l'avez dit sentiment d'impunité laxisme
pénale philippe benassaya l'emportent
finalement avec 57% des suffrages le 27
septembre deux ans plus tard le député
souhaite être réélu il a d'ores et déjà
annoncé sa candidature
c'est un travail très intéressant que
j'ai envie de poursuivre d'abord pour
défendre les habitants dans une
circonscription mais également défendre
nos élus qui ont besoin de relais au
niveau national pour pouvoir engranger
les projets et puis bien sûr être aux
côtés de nos artisans commerçants et de
nos entreprises
génération s n'a pas encore nommé son
candidat pour le premier tour prévu le
12 juin prochain le parti attend de voir
les autres candidatures de gauche pour
adopter une stratégie quant à la
république en marche l'objectif sera la
reconquête il y aura des députés de la
république en marche en tout cas des
candidats dans toutes les
circonscriptions yvelinoise après benoît
hamon pour le parti socialiste en 2012
nadia et de l erp m en 2017 et philippe
benassaya en 2020 trois voix semble
ouverte à cinq mois du premier tour
autre candidat potentiel la france
insoumise et le rassemblement national
qui étaient tous deux aux alentours de
7% lors du précédent scrutin
elle a été inaugurée ce samedi la
navette électrique la belle boucle de
maurepas a fait ses premiers kilomètres
aujourd'hui une navette gratuite mise en
place par la municipalité qui permettra
aux seniors maurepas vient de se
déplacer dans la ville le mercredi jeudi
et samedi de 8h30 à 12h30 doté de 13
places assises et l'effectuera 22 arrêts
dans la ville en une heure les places
sont soumise à réservation il faut avoir
plus de soixante deux ans et bénéficier
d'un passeport seniors pour en profiter
véronique milot maire adjoint délégué
aux seniors nous en parle l'objectif de
cette navette c'est de faciliter la
mobilité des seniors de leur permettre
l'accès aux différentes infrastructures
services pour l'intérêt de la ville
voilà comme les centres commerciaux
paris ouest le centre ville les centres
médicaux également au préalable donc
s'inscrire la veille avant midi voilà
donc ensuite le chauffeur donc s'arrête
à l'arrêt réservés et puis on mène la
personne à destination une interview au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude avec
céline charles et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis dans un instant retrouver mélanie
poké à la présentation de votre 7,8
société très bonne soirée à tous sur tv
[Musique]